crews from our local red cross also
preparing to deploy kate houston spoke
to some locals who have friends and
family in louisiana who say they need
all the help they can get
it's going to take a few days for these
bands to get down to the gulf coast
volunteers here will be providing food
and water to those who desperately need
it red cross volunteer ed lockwood will
join four other southern nevadans
already stationed in the area he will
take this van through different
neighborhoods it can hold enough meals
to feed 300 people although the
volunteers don't have their location
just yet reports of damage are coming in
from major cities like new orleans to
small fishing towns like lockport
louisiana the gulf coast is no stranger
to devastating winds and flooding but
las vegas locals like lorena are now
worried for their friends and family who
have to deal with this on top of the
pandemic
not only is the hurricane you know
people
don't can't pay their rent on time
because of jobs being lost and now look
the hurricane and they have to actually
evacuate their home and lose so much
stuff the wind and the rain and
everything just coming through it's i
just
very emotional i was emotional yesterday
too talking about it and all that the
american red cross says it will be many
days before they see the extent of the
damage from hurricane ida they
anticipate being on site for weeks if
not months to help the community
especially those still recovering from
last hurricane season
kate houston 8 news now
there are about 600 red cross volunteers
who are on site right now and our crews
will be deployed as we said earlier
probably for a couple of weeks